家から出たらエヴァンゲリオンがいるドッキリ位
[音楽]
はいただいま絶賛映画公開中なんですけども
エヴァすごくない深みためエヴァンゲリオン初号機とかすごい有名なんですけどもう体
が細いロボットっていうのって結構やつ感があるので朝起きて何となく玄関から出た時
にバンディ音が目の前に行ったら相当びっくりするのかなと思って今回やっていきたい
と思います今回僕が変身するのはえーっ
ああああああ
ショゴ日ではなく
13号機へヱヴァンゲリヲン新劇場版 q で13号機っていう結構所合金にてるん
ですけどもう1回戦で行くと渚カヲル君ら2人で乗るっていう期待があるんですよと
いうことで
うん
今日は渚カヲル君にお越しいただいています宜しくお願いします
待たせたね隼士くん地学あっはは w エンドに4好きなんで
た委員会はマット寸胴で2人でエヴァ13号機に
乗れないんでアン手伝ってもらえますかこれほどがれると思った
では早速下今回のコスプレ見ていきましょうすごいっすよエバーのコース期から作っ
終わりますヤバってない功績を作る
いやが過ぎますそれもちゃんと採寸で体の全パーツの位置を計算してもうハゲ者としか
着れない作りになってますそれだけ体の細いから
いくゲーム
外まで細くしてもらえますか楽しく見ていきますねうわぁやばい日でー
vivi でぱぱっ日ねー
やばいってこれで胴体でやるぞなんていうとまずヤバイぞ
a 強い起きるのでこの光沢
なにこれなにこれレッツだね年々なんだこれ
こんな分あったっていう多分どこかさようなパーツでしょ
ちょっと本当にまだわからんだからこそ手足て座ったねー
かっこよすぎでしょこれこれが足ですね
年か接着剤とか入ってるんだけどえっ
にぞトレンカちょっと接着剤の意図は分からないけどこれが顔ですねやっぱりなんか顔
がすっげーデリケートらしくてもう放送の仕方は見たら分かると思うんですけど相当
慎重に扱われてくれました
うわぁ凄い凄い凄い
あっはっは
ua 金でやばいぜなんて本当にすごいよこれ頭だけ飾っておきたよ
yeah
待ってマジでかっこいいんだけど
13号機の頭ですやばくない
カットでこんな覚悟がある
ニャンバー愛と上でこれがエヴァ13号機のコスプレセット
観光俺専用です俺の体にはほんとフィットしてるんで切っちゃうたぶんすごくなると
思います早速着ていきましょう
ねば
エヴァ量産中宜しくお願いします誰かリオさんがですかまずさんこれ多分それができる
と大量死を知ってた
[音楽]
腕は二世を入れるん
これたぶん段位がね堪えば13呼吸で
4判カラー目ダルいですね本当にどうすんだこれ
こんな複雑な星である
うわぁすっげー切りらプラグ雪針にプチっちゃういっ
うわあああああ
ギリギリよおすすめはい保険をはすごい
半径これは自分でいけそう
はいはいはいはいはい次なんですけども
今回ですね今の顔頭に来てるんじゃないんですよ
まあ顔が小さすぎるんで俺の頭ために[ __ ]って乗せる感じなんで今からここに火を
付けています
つきましたよし
ねっかっこよではかぶっていきますまあこれむずいね
宇津井っていうのがおいでよもあるからねパパ
感じでも両手か行かなきゃダメだこれこれでご覧くださいはい
[音楽]
a オレちょっとこれ
万歳もちょっと泣いてがは酢を混ぜてるツイートはあります
うわぁすっ
ブーブー歯科
はやるですまずは1本はいん
思う何やらせにいうかこれだってさー
ね1通算も一例
[音楽]
マインドよくで完成しました
どうか中ですというわけで無事エヴァ13号機になることができたのでこれでさあ
ゲットもいいです
待とうと思います
どうぞん
[音楽]
me
[拍手]
[音楽]
はぁ
voodoo
ああああああ
dai
畦れまええええ
ええええええ
実際にガールめちゃてくれと言っちゃんって誰
goo
持っています
me
そうだ貞らが挙げる
ています
ああああああ
[音楽]
がくださいん
me
やばい結構な今日値からさーすごい汗が
ねはいいうわけで腕4本で失礼しますただいまですね全国の劇場で公開されているシン
エヴァンゲリオンの劇場版なんですけれども宣伝担当の方が来て何か僕のチャンネルを
見てくださっているということでありがたいことに今回エヴァンゲリオンのお仕事
いただきましたありがとうございますこんな素敵な
腕まで反映とエヴァンゲリオンなんですけどももうなんか本当に僕の成長とともに歩ん
できたアニメだと思っててそれがついに最終章ということですごい考え深いというか僕
自身すごい思い入れのアニメなまで新劇場版見たんですけど
でよかったですエヴァンゲリオンちょっと難しいかなって簿からにいらっしゃると思い
ますけどもそんなことありません進撃ジョマンっていう3作品があるんですけども
をこれ見れば内容とっても分かりやすいですこの3作品を見れば
エヴァンゲにを知らない方でも今劇場でている深夜番組の劇場版
ずう2分に楽しめると思いますのでまずそちら見てみてください掃除ですねなんと6月
12日から入場者特典でこっちが今話題のエヴァの薄い本の内容がまずでやばいんです
よてぃく衝撃
がページとか感動するようなページがあったりするんですけどもこちらなんと100万
部限定の超レアものでございますぜひゲットしてみてください上で詳しくは動画の概要
欄にありますのでぜひチェックしてみてください僕はを見に行ったんですけどももう1
回は必ず行くと思いますでエヴァンゲリオンを楽しんでください今回食べた13号機は
大津に飾らせていただき
ません
あっはぁし